hey everyone its Johanna here today we
want to define our waistline and add
more curves to our body if you have an
athletic body type or a hedge frame just
like hayden Panettiere then you are more
likely to have a broad shoulders or
strong back and a less curvy waist line
so we want to focus on a lot of rotation
exercises to tighten the midsection
which can help to define your waistline
we want to focus on high repetitions and
avoid using heavy weights which may add
more bulge to your waistline so start
with a quick warmup and let's start
twisting those hips so each exercise
will last 30 seconds and let's start
with one of the best core workout which
is bicycle crunches okay so lie on your
back get ready
legs up and twist good so look up to
avoid neck pain and really bring your
knees to your elbows good keep twisting
you should feel your lower abs working
your upper abs and also your obliques
which is your waist line good keep going
ten more seconds and the second workout
is double leg circles
ready straight into it lift your legs up
and make a circle clockwise
okay the lower you bring your legs the
more you will feel on your lower abs
good five more seconds and we will
change side good change side let's go
bring it up keep your legs as straight
as possible only go as low as you can
without arching your back next workout W
crunches so bring your body up extend
your arms leg straight and just try to
slide your hands along your legs and
feel your right side I'll feel oblique
working so your arms should only be
supporting you and not helping you to
leave your body up good keep going
through the right side and of the days
we want to work on the left side one
more good and switch over let's go
crunch up good ah
rich nice so remember your arms should
only support your body and not pushing
off the floor you really want to live
your legs up and crunch all the way up
nice and then find a core workout is
mountain climber
we want to add some cardio in so up and
let's go straight body give me 30
seconds of mountain climber adding some
cardio will help to burn that off the
waistline as well kick keep going
straight back look straight ahead and
then you will get your 30 seconds rest
keep going keep climbing as fast as you
can one more and rest and we want to
repeat this entire circuit once more all
right so let's start with bicycle
crunches again lie down on the floor
get ready you have 10 more seconds rest
go
each workout without resting okay so
bicycle crunches leave your legs up keep
challenging yourself each time go crunch
look up okay really aim to lift your
shoulders off the floor and not your
neck so just gently support your neck
without pulling your back good keep
twisting nice so bring your leg as low
as you can without our shoulder back and
just need to breathe them out next
double leg surface up let's go talk wise
nice good very good your low abs working
as low as you can alright and now switch
over and to top wise get really tighten
your core in order to tighten the
midsection and oblique crunches right
now so relax clench up again slide your
arms just along your feet and leave your
legs up you should feel to the right
side of your oblique working okay as
much as you can
small crunches but you will give this
section where you can good do more with
us and let's swap over I'm off
ready go extend up nice really crunchy
whoa good job Oh breathe out
few more and just use your my arm to
support yourself
good keep feeling your left obliques
working and one up today's the dreaded
mountain climber let's go up on your
feet and go get look straight ahead keep
your body upright and really push in
keeping all you can nice
this is your one workout and you get a
full 1 minute rest
so keep grinding keep going good come on
bring your knees in figureheads working
five more seconds keep crunching and
rest and just relax right now you have a
full one-minute break because we want to
move on to our second round where we
will be working on a lot of plants so
take this time to stretch your body out
relax drink some water and get ready for
a lot of plants to really tighten those
meat sections ok
so 15 more seconds the first workout we
want to start with spider-man plank the
Hollis variation we'll be reaching out
and crunching in balance itself and
crunch in if this is time just put your
arms on the floor and just crunch in
okay so choose a variation let's go
Beach I'll crunch in out and in so this
requires a lot of balance which requires
you to work more on your core at the
same time all working on the side of
your blade
good do you want one more and let's
change slightly up crunch out crunch you
will find one side it's less balance
which is my left side crunch out and
crunch good one more and now let's go to
cross plank
let me - right elbows okay cross leg
good so big crunch and try to bring your
knees close to your elbows nice keep
going crunch opposite side twist oblique
rotate those hips keep your butt down so
do not bring about too high up few more
and we want to work on site plan so get
onto your right side bring your knees
legs up okay on your shoulders drop it
it's lift it up drop your hips lift it
up and just drop squeeze the side of
your waistline okay good
the next one we want to work on the left
side okay if this is difficult beginners
you can start on your knees and let's
change up okay and drop your waist okay
you can always start on your elbows as
well with this rear variation which will
make it easier if you want to add it to
make it more challenging then go on to
the palms of your hand ten more seconds
and we want to add some plank plyo into
the workout right so onto your hands and
I'm going to jump in out in and out okay
that's it
supply up to your plank so you are
working on your hips and also the side
of your waist in I'm trying not to step
on my phone
good ten more seconds in in good that's
three more keep going stay strong
one more and just rest it out thirty
seconds rest we want to repeat this
entire circuit once more all right so
let's start with spider-man plank and
you can choose which variation you want
to work with let me just put my phone
head you further away right let's go get
into spider-man plank ready reach out
and crunch it good out and in tighten
your core to balance yourself nice keep
crunching crunch
reach one more and change side reach
right I got to really tie to my core to
balance myself on my left side the next
workout straight into cross plank
let's go cross plank knees to elbows
opposite side good really twist rotate
those hips and reach the further you
reach the more you will crunch doing
good into relax your shoulders so not
too much tension on your shoulders keep
crossing plus two more give flight plan
okay harder variation get on to the
pumps of the hand drop your hips crunch
it up very very nice drop your hips
crunch look straight ahead
to find your balance drop and really
push all the way up so not a little bit
go a high as high as you can ah one more
good switch over
let's go up onto the palms of your hand
let yourself down and up nice can I see
those smiles good whoa you are almost at
the end of your workout so stay strong
and we have one more fly your plank
drop squeeze drop squeeze up few more
one more and let's get straight into fly
your plank jump okay jump good let's go
get going
give me all your energy good you're
halfway there
keep going jump a little bit of cardio
would do you love good keep going ten
more seconds
bring it out few more one more and just
relax rip it all engines relax your
tongue well done so the challenge
yourself repeated this entire video once
more and aim to do this workout two to
three times weekly for best result
combine this exercise together with your
regular cardio as strength training for
authentic body shapes you can combine
this workout together with my exercises
for Apple body shapes which will help to
turn up on your other body which means
less broad shoulders and back and to
increase molding muscles into your lower
body which can help to define your
waistline even more all the best for new
Fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
You Tube channel and website do follow
me on Facebook Instagram and Twitter to
stay connected with me thanks guys
you